Hello 大家好,今天的影片想跟大家聊一個話題,就是怎樣建立一個股票研究和分析的框架。
在這個框架當中,
基本面分析和圖形分析各自承擔什麼樣的角色,
以及如何將這兩個方面結合起來,
讓我們的投資邏輯更加的完整。
所謂基本面分析框架,簡單來說就是三個方面,商業模式,財務表現,市場定價。
所謂商業模式呢
就是說這家公司做什麼生意
賺誰的錢
是2B的生意還是2C的生意
那麼賺錢的方式是不是有壟斷性
是不是有護城河
能不能夠這個業務無限的擴大
它的生意有沒有天花板
所以這些都是我們做投資
最基礎的一些底層模具
如果說在五分鐘之內
你無法回答這些問題的話
那說明你可能對這家公司的
這個生意無法理解
那麼無法理解的生意
我的看法就是最好不要碰
我認為一家偉大的公司
它的產品應該具備
四個基本條件
第一個無差別的產品
第二最廣泛的用戶
第三自由定價
第四市場壟斷
最典型的例子就是Google
它的產品是無差別的
你使用的Google和我使用的Google
本質上說沒有任何差別
全球80億人和全球絕大多數的企業
都需要Google的服務
都是它的潛在客戶
那麼Google的產品定價
沒有政府或者是某個機構來限制它的價格
那麼Google在很多產品很多服務方面
是具有壟斷特性的
比如說Google的搜索是絕對的壟斷者
此外它的Android系統
Chrome瀏覽器
Google Map
Google Cloud
Gmail
還有就是你現在正在看的這個YouTube
也是一個絕對性的壟斷產品
所以我認為做投資啊
就要投資這樣的生意
有了這些大概的這種商業認知之後呢
那麼我們就可以進入第二層
就可以看財務表現
財務表現呢
主要是看三個三類數據
首先是看收入
包括收入的規模
收入的成長性
那麼然後是看這個運營利潤率
也就是EBIT margin
它是用來考察企業的核心的盈利能力的
如果說運營利潤是負值
那說明這家企業屬於是結構性的虧損
說明這家企業的商業模式可能存在問題
第三個就是看現金流
現金流包括運營現金流和自由現金流
運營現金流就是說
這個企業在商業運營的過程當中產生的現金流
自由現金流就是說
商業運營過程當中的現金流
減去它的資本支出
剩下來的部分就是自由現金流
我是比較看重這個自由現金流
因為自由現金流
它才是企業真正賺到的錢
這些多出來的現金流
可以用於擴大它的生產規模
或者說是開發新的產品
或者說是收購其他的企業
或者說用分紅
或者說是回購股份的方式
來回饋它的股東
這都是可以的
也就是說具備強大自由現金流的企業
它的生意
它的生意的彈性就非常好
可攻可守
那麼我比較喜歡的企業
有幾下幾個特徵
你可以記一下
首先第一個就是說
這家企業的收入不應該小於一億美元
年收入一億美元
已經是一個非常大的體量
那麼有這個體量的企業
它就已經進入了一個叫做什麼呢
實力比較強
身體比較好
同時呢市場影響力也比較大的這樣的一個階段
跨過這個門檻
你不要以為一億美元
一億美元很多企業是跨不過去的
絕大多數企業在碰到一億美元就再也過不去了
那麼能過去的
它就會進入一個良性的快速的發展階段
那麼這個體量的企業
那麼我們可以預期
它每年有15%到20%左右的一個收入增速
這麼大的體量
如果說收入增速低於10%
那麼我認為它可能存在一些動力不足的情況
發展可能就碰到了一個瓶頸
那麼太高的增速
比如說40% 50%的這種增速的話
也很難維持
所以說我認為1億美元的年收入的這種規模的企業
它的成長性在15%到20%是比較理想
是一種可持續的狀態
那麼接下去就是看它的運營利潤率了
在同行業當中
同一種生意類型的企業當中
運營利潤率越高越好
對吧
那麼運營利潤率越高
它的這個抗風險的空間就越大
彈性就越大
當然這個運營利潤率呢
是不可能不可以跨行業比較的
不同的商業模式
它的利潤率是不同的
比如說谷歌可以做到
32%的這個運營利潤率
但是沃爾瑪只有4
但是你不能說沃爾瑪的4%
就一定比Google的32%要差
不是這樣的
因為它的商業模式是不同的
但是我們可以用沃爾瑪的4%的運營利潤率
去和Costco的3.7%的運營利潤率做比較
那麼這樣的一種比較
我們可以看得出來
沃爾瑪的企業的運行效率
就要比Costco要高一點點
這種同業比較才有意義
然後就是看運營現金流
我認為運營現金流
必須是正值
這表達你做生意
是可以賺到錢的
運營現金流是負值
就說明你不掙錢
那麼在運營現金流
是正值的前提下
自由現金流最好也是正值
前面已經說了
自由現金流是一個企業
可以自由拿來
隨意做一些變動的
一些彈性的商業活動的
這樣的一個可能性
前面說到的這幾個財務數據
我們可以用來驗證一家企業
它的商業模式到底靠不靠譜
是不是已經走上了正軌
我這種篩選方式
也是刻意排除掉了那些
目前還停留在講故事的
那個階段的股票
如果是一個好企業
你的故事真的能夠成真的話
那我相信你終有一天
會跨過這個門檻
進入到我的股票池當中的
之前我有一個網友
他跟我討論一隻股票
那麼這隻股票我看了一下
確實這隻股票
有很多很多的動聽的故事
又是什麼遠程醫療
又是這個AI概念
又是這個叫什麼
國會山股神佩洛西的磁場
但是你打開報表一看
這家公司是屬於結構性虧損的狀態
EBIT margin是小於零的
債務甚至大於收入
它完全沒有產生現金流的能力
那麼如果像這樣的一家企業
最近這個股票也走得比較弱
還跑不贏大盤
那麼我不知道這位網友
他在賭什麼
對不對
在我的觀念當中
如果說一隻完全靠故事驅動的股票
一旦弱於大盤
就必須要果斷拋棄了
那當然這是一個
另外一種叫做動量投資的策略
這個話題呢
我會找時間來專門做一個影片
來講一講這個動量投資的事情
當我們找到了靠譜的企業之後
我們就需要看它的市場定價
市場定價不是股價高低
而是指估值
所謂估值
就是我們常用的估值指標
PSPE PB
這些指標其實都在表達同一個意思
就是說這家企業的市場價值
和它的商業價值之間的關係
估值的意義在於
讓我們瞭解市場預期
相類似的企業當中
估值較高的企業
說明投資者給予的更高的預期
估值高有高的道理
低有低的道理
我們沒有必要去與它計較
我有一篇文章是專門講估值的
有興趣的朋友可以去看一下
總而言之
但是基本面並不需要多麼深厚的財務基礎
有一些基本的商業邏輯的這些常識
你能夠掌握我前面說到的這些幾個重要的一些內容就夠了
不是越多越好
基本面分析框架主要解決一個定性的問題
但是呢
它不能夠解決具體操作的問題
我有一句名言叫做基本面不可以用來做交易
因為有很多財務數據
看上去非常好的企業
它的股價可以一直跌
所以說怎樣做交易
怎樣買入賣出這些事情
這就屬於是技術面的範疇
那麼我們講技術面的範疇
或者技術面框架
主要看三個方面
趨勢
位置和風險管理
我另外還有一個名言
多數時候我們賺的都是趨勢的錢
關於趨勢呢
我這裡有一個影片
做過詳細的講解
簡單的來說呢
我把價格趨勢分成五個
十種方向來表示
一點鐘到十二點鐘方向的趨勢方向
這表明市場對這個企業的生意
是極度看好
甚至有點瘋狂的
那麼兩點鐘左右的這個趨勢方向
它表達市場的認可度是比較高的
投資者是比較樂觀的
那麼三點鐘方向
那很顯然就是一種猶豫啊
懷疑啊和不信任的一種態度
那麼四點鐘方向的趨勢
表達市場不認可
比較悲觀
那麼五點到六點鐘的這種方向
表達市場極度的不相信
或者不看好企業的這種商業前景
投資者極度悲觀這樣的一種狀態
我們研究趨勢
所謂趨勢
趨勢的作用就在於
它是已知信息和未知信息之間的橋樑
舉個例子來說
我們看這家企業
它的收入持續增長
很不錯
對不對
經營現金流
自由現金流也很不錯
運營利潤率也保持一個比較高比較穩定的水平
但是呢
股價卻這段時間是持續的下跌
PS估值已經跌回到了歷史最低水平的附近
股價和基本面朝著完全相反的方向運行
這說明有些事情我們可能不知道
價格趨勢告訴我們市場不看好這家企業的商業前景
像這樣的股票
我的經驗是不要去抄底
暫時不要碰
至少要看到這個股價
這個逐漸往上
逐漸這個基本面和股價
能夠配合往上的時候
那麼股價已經形成了
這種一定的上漲趨勢之後
再進入
這樣的話呢
就是相對的安全
那麼我會更傾向於
做這種兩點鐘方向趨勢的
這種股票
基本面往這裡走
那麼股價也是往這個方向走
這個基本面和股價
相互驗證同步上漲的股票
這樣的股票
有市場共識拿得住
也是最容易賺到錢的一種方式
那麼技術框架的第二個層面
就是位置
我們經常說這個位置那個位置
所謂位置就是一些歷史上
這個投資者關於這隻股票的供應價格
我們一般的股票圖表上
橫軸是時間
縱軸是價格
成交量表達此時市場參與者
對這個股票的看法
對不對
那麼成交量還有另外一種表達方式
就是縱向的籌碼分佈
它表達的是在選定的時間範圍之內
某一些價格上的成交量的堆積
某個價格附近出現的
較大的成交量堆積
我們叫做籌碼峰
那麼籌碼峰就是說明
這個地方是有市場共識的
這個價格有大量的人參與
有市場共識
那麼籌碼峰越大
這個市場共識就越大
籌碼峰就可以看作是市場的供應價格
供應價格通常會有這種阻力和支撐的作用
在上漲趨勢過程當中
價格回撤到某一個重要的籌碼峰附近的時候
這裡往往會形成價格的支撐作用
那麼下跌過程當中
當它反彈碰到某一個重要的籌碼峰的時候
這裡可能會起到一定的阻力的作用
這些重要的位置其實就是可以用來幫助我們判斷
這個位置是可以買入或者賣出的位置
因為這裡有大量的市場共識
這個共識對我們來說是相對安全的
前面我說這個基本面不可以用來做交易
那麼交易怎麼做
結合上面的籌碼這些價格我們來說一下
我的經驗是第一
找到你喜歡的商業模式
找到一個你認為靠譜的生意
然後在它的股價
最好是運行在兩點鐘方向
左右的方向
那麼怎麼看這個時間呢
我這裡有個影片
大家再去看一下
我這裡就不多說了
最重要的是
兩點鐘方向的趨勢
等它的股價回撤
它總是要回撤
對不對
你就耐心等就是了
等股價回撤到重要的籌碼峰的附近
重要的供應價值的附近買入
前提是什麼
它的總體的趨勢是往上
兩點鐘方向
它的總體的商業狀況
財務狀況也是朝著這個方向
這種股票才可以做
當然了圖形不是萬能的
圖形裡面有各種各樣的
這種錯誤信號
特別是某些小股票
流動性很差的
這個價格也容易被操縱
但是不管怎麼樣
無論如何
不管你是否看好這個企業
或者說是怎麼樣
你記住一句話
任何一筆交易
最重要的是要有預期
很多人是有預期沒錯
同時要有底線
所謂底線就是我們的風險邊界
絕大多數人在股市上的虧損
都是因為沒有底線導致的
或者說即使有底線
跌破底線也不肯認輸的結果
十幾年前我也曾經犯過一次
這樣的重大的錯誤
損失慘重
當時我的股票出現了持續下跌的情況
但是根據我當時的掌握的財務數據
各個方面的信息
以及我對這家股票
我自認為我對這家公司非常的瞭解
所以我堅持認為我沒有錯
市場錯了
所以我硬扛了很長時間
還逢低加倉了很多
但是最終連續兩個季度的財務數據
說明證明我看錯了
並且財報當中公佈了企業管理層
出現了嚴重的
或者說是明顯的這種決策失誤
但是這種事情
我是無法從公開信息當中及時獲得的
總之最後是一個慘敗出局的結果
直到今天這隻股票
還沒有漲回到我當初忍痛割肉的位置
但是這件事情
對我形成了非常大的影響
它也成為了我投資生涯當中
最重要的一條教訓
就是說當圖形
與我的預期方向不一致的時候
我應該尊重圖形的方向
因為總有一些事情我不知道
然而圖形中
其實已經包含了這些信息了
總之任何一筆交易
有預期
有底線
有計劃
最重要的是一計形式
這個三有加一直行的原則
是打開財富之門的金鑰匙
它不僅用於我們做投資
做股票
它同樣適用於我們平時的做人做事
最後總結一下
企業基本面框架用來定性
是一個值不值得參與
打不打得贏的一個戰略問題
如果這家公司這家企業
生意上有問題不值得投資
你根本就不要考慮後面的事情
你就忽略
另外再找就好了
那麼技術框架問題
它是用來指導我們的具體交易的
是怎樣打贏的一個戰術問題
孫子兵法當中有兩句經典
我分享給大家
第一句叫做
知可以戰與不可以戰者勝
第二句
善戰者勝於異勝者也
這兩句話是我自己做投資
做交易
甚至做人做事的最高指導原則
好就說這些
我們下期節目再見
拜拜